how do we move the united states china
russia india
uh european union to to a bitcoin
standard
i'm not entirely concerned about whether
governments move or not in fact i'd be
very happy
for them not to move as long as possible
so that individuals can accumulate more
and more bitcoin while it's still cheap
so the people will move
and the governments will catch up
yeah and i think this is kind of what i
allude to i mean the point of the fiat
standard fiat standard is really a
bitcoin book and it talks about fiat
most of the time but it's
does so to analyze bitcoin and the rise
of bitcoin in the final chapter i
discuss how i think this relationship
plays out
um
i i the way that i tend to think of it
is that most likely what's going to
happen is we're going to have kind of uh
financial apartheid where there's going
to be two monetary systems
one is government controlled
and it comes with increasing amounts of
surveillance and inflation
and then if you want you can just opt
out of that and get into bitcoin and
it's likely going to be difficult for
governments to stop people from getting
into bitcoin
for all the technical reasons that make
it very hard to stop bitcoin
so then we have this alternative that is
bitcoin which is not inflationary and
does not have a central authority that
can censor it
i think
um
gradually is my hope and i also think my
most likely scenario but maybe i am
biased because
everybody thinks what they want is
what's going to happen
i think we're just going to witness you
know the same relationship because
governments
make their currency so that they can
devalue them
and bitcoin thrives on that and more and
more people are going to learn more and
more people are going to find out and
whether it's through
curiosity or self-interest or through
the destruction of the national currency
all roads lead to bitcoin so more and
more people are going to buy bitcoin the
price of bitcoin is going to go up and
as it goes up bitcoin becomes a more
significant part of the world economy
and this is this is something that the
skeptics don't get like a lot of the
academic skeptics to bitcoin you know
they they offer up all of these theories
about why
they think bitcoin can't work and then
they present it and they think you know
they've delivered the knockout blow as
if bitcoin needs their permission or the
word is going to need their permission
well the reality is people are going to
join bitcoin out of greed out of
self-interest number go up technology is
is really what's going to get everybody
in yeah and that's really the trojan
horse for
fixing the world you know come for the
greed and stay for the revolution
it's gonna keep going up because people
don't like to be poor
except for most economists and academics
people don't like to be poor people
don't enjoy getting their wealth
destroyed and they care more about their
self-interest than they care about
economic theories about whether this
works as money or not they see their
cousin escaped hyperinflation managed to
get a bigger house because they bought
bitcoin five years ago they realized
maybe i should stop
um mocking my cousin and start buying
more bitcoin and this is i think an
indomitable force that's going to
continue
and one thing
um
most bitcoiners tend to lean toward an
apocalyptic transition you know this
fiat's gonna collapse we're gonna get
hyperinflation everything's gonna be
terrible and then we're gonna move to
bitcoin
and i present the case for why i think
maybe that might not be the case maybe
we won't get this kind of apocalyptic
scenario
and it's becau and this was like the
conclusion of the fiat standard which is
once you realize that mining fiat is
creating debt
and bitcoin is allowing so in order to
have fiat money we need to have people
borrow we need to have people make loans
and
the problem
that fiat money runs into today is that
if you want to save money if you want to
hold savings
you have a problem where do you put your
savings so you put your savings in debt
in the creation of more bonds
wherever you take your savings you
create a bubble in those things and this
is why we see a bubble in the stock
market a bubble in the bond market
bubbling housing it's because people are
looking for savings looking for a place
where they can save all those things are
crappy saving instruments because
they're like
the they're like copper in that there's
nothing to stop the people behind them
to make more of them house
builders can build more houses
governments can issue more bonds
um the crappy fraudulent companies can
list on the stock market and make more
stocks
well bitcoin finally offers us an outlet
we don't need to keep creating more debt
we can invest in this asset that is hard
and that is internationally liquid
and that nobody can make more of so
there is no bubble in it there is no
mechanism for
somebody to increase the supply and
bring the price crashing down like with
copper and real estate and bonds
so bitcoin is the way out and this is
why i think there's a good case to be
made for why the fiat authorities
might embrace bitcoin because they'll
see it is their way out of this
enormous um debt bubble that everybody
is stuck in
particularly the richest and most
powerful people in the world
and the richest and most powerful
governments in the world are the world's
biggest borrowers they're the ones in a
lot of debt so a continuous slow
devaluation of the value of that debt
as people upgrade and move on to a hard
asset that continues to appreciate
is
the way that we is the peaceful way that
we wind down the fiat ponzi i think you
could see it being like a political part
of a political platform for future
people that run for president those
kinds of things to address
obviously
it's not just for the powerful and the
rich
the people are bothered by the debt
the people are bothered by everything
that you describe with fiat and if you
want to
sell yourself in a democracy as a good
leader you might want to make that part
of the platform
you